good morning and welcome to the
Commission's press room today is
Thursday the 30th of January and it is
our pleasure to have with us executive
vice president miss tagger who will be
discussing with us an antitrust decision
effectively as president welcome well
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here today the Commission has decided
to find nbc/universal together with
other companies in the Comcast Group
fourteen point three million euros for
anti-competitive licensing and
distributing distribution practices
which are illegal under EU antitrust
rules NBCUniversal is a US company that
operates television networks and film
and TV producing companies all around
the world it also owns property rights
to the characters in its movies and the
themes the images and the logos from
those movies and it licenses hundreds of
companies in Europe to make and sell
products which uses that intellectual
property things like Jurassic Park toys
minions school bags and Shrek NOx in
return those licensees they pay
nbc/universal part of their sales
revenue as royalty you can find these
products in millions of Europeans homes
European home if you have children
that's a pretty good chance that it will
be in your home too NBC Universal
illegal behavior well that affected a
full range of those products from toys
and sweets to clothes and marks and
household
it's contracts with licensees divided up
the European single market and that took
away choice from consumers and may also
have effects its prices our
investigation found that nbc/universal
used contracts to set out which
countries these licenses could sell in
and which ones they were banned from in
some contracts NBC Universal also
limited their freedom to sell products
online it even gave some licensees a
list of customer customers that they
were allowed to sell to and these
restrictions meant that shops couldn't
freely choose which products actually to
order from different European
distributors a department store in Spain
couldn't sell and ET pajamas from a
Belgian manufacturer because that
manufacturer was banned from selling
into Spain so the extra-terrestrial may
have made it all the way to earth but
was banned from Spain because of
contractual restrictions meanwhile a
teenager in sweden couldn't buy himself
a big lebowski
t-shirts online so as a result of these
restrictions while consumers they lost
out on choice and probably also on lower
prices in short consumers retailers
licensees they were all deprived of the
benefits from the single market and
today's decision makes it clear that
brand owners cannot prohibit their
non-exclusive licensees from selling in
some Member States or to certain
customers or from selling online these
illegal behavior lasted for more than
six years started in the beginning of
2013 when nbc/universal increase
it's licensed thing activities in Europe
that was ahead of the launch of the
sequel to the various successful movie
Despicable Me it lasted until September
2019 when in the course of our
investigation
NBC told all its European licensees that
those anti-competitive sales
restrictions no longer applied and this
is why we have imposed a fine of
fourteen point three million euros NBC
Universal cooperates with the Commission
in our investigation it acknowledged the
infringement and provided additional
evidence and they did that relatively
early in the process as a result the
company was granted a 30% reduction of
the fine this sort of cooperation is now
a well-established antitrust procedure
in the last two years we have adopted
ten decisions involving companies that
has cooperated that have cooperated with
us and that is good news because it
means that we can enforce antitrust
rules faster and more efficiently so why
does it matter it's a small fine well
there are two good reasons first of all
because those this those restrictions is
all about merchandising the second one
is much broader this industry the
merchandising industry
well that is big business and it's
growing rapidly in Europe and around the
world and it's expected to keep growing
the merchandise sector in in Europe is
estimated to be worth around fifty
billion euros last year from a global
total of 230 billion euros and today's
decision is the third antitrust decision
which the Commission has taken in the
merchandise sector in less than a
year in March last year we find Nike for
a similar behavior including products
that carries Football Club brands like
FC Barcelona or Ventus and in July we
find Sanrio for a similar infringement
to do with the merchandise featuring
Hello Kitty and other characters these
three decisions they send a clear
message the commission will not tolerate
restrictions that undermine the single
market and that brings me to the second
reason why this decision is important
because the single market makes a vital
contribution to our prosperity it
provides a better deal for consumers and
more opportunities for businesses
today's decision is part of our drive to
make sure that the single market works
well the single market gives businesses
the potential to reach out to almost
half a billion consumers and
digitization has made it even easier for
consumers to buy and for businesses to
sell across borders in the European
Union and that ought to create
opportunities for businesses of course
including digital businesses to grow but
in practice there are still a number of
obstacles to sell across border even
today only one in five European
consumers buys online from retailers in
other member states so completing the
single market is an important part of
making Europe fit for the digital age
the obstacles to a for single market
comes in many form
including the contracts that stop
retailers from selling cross-border
within the European Union the sector
inquiry into e-commerce markets which we
carried out in the Commission's last
term well we found that territorial
restrictions they were actually becoming
increasingly common
both in contracts for the sale of
consumer goods online and for those
licensing digital products and this is
why it has been a priority for us to
tackle anti-competitive restrictions to
online and offline cross-border sales
for example we you find gas for limiting
the ability of distributors of its
clothes and accessories to sell
cross-border and online and we find
manufacturers of consumer electronics
for limiting cross-border sales for
pressuring their online retailers to
keep prices high with today's decision
the total fine with imposed on companies
for creating barriers to cross-border
trade in the single market comes to a
hundred and eighty four million euros
and this is since we completed the
sector inquiry in May 2017 this is
complemented by other parts of the
Commission's work take for example the
do blocking regulation which aims at
removing unjustified geo blocking when
they restricts online shopping so
today's decision is not just about
minions and dinosaurs and throws it's
about consumers and businesses in the
singer market it shows that the
Commission is committed to making every
effort to make sure that the single
market throughout Europe is working
better for us all thank you